[Music]
I'm Paul I am a product manager at
Google and I work on Apps Script dot
script among a couple of other products
I'm curious how many of you in the
audience have used Apps Script before or
are familiar with it or whether this is
folks first time awesome so this talk is
definitely designed for somebody who
hasn't seen Apps Script before and it's
an easy product to demo in that way
because it's based on JavaScript which
is something that many or all of you
already know and so just to tell you a
little bit about myself my broader team
is the Apps developer team and we work
on extensibility and automation and
integration for G suite and I focus on
on Apps Script in particular I was
previously a startup founder and CTO and
in that role and in this one I know the
the challenge that comes with
prioritization I would imagine that we
all have the experience of somebody
approaching us with whatever level of
urgency telling us about the project
that needs to get done or the process
that needs to get implemented and if the
easy things aren't easy then the hard
things don't get done and that is to say
we have to prioritize ruthlessly in our
jobs and I an easy technology lets us go
from doing 5% of the things that we want
to do to 10 or 15% and that can be a
really big difference for those users
who are affected by that that second 5
or 10%
I'm a big believer in serverless
development and you've probably already
been hearing a lot about serverless here
at next it's something that Google is
thinking hard about across the platform
and Apps Script is one of the places and
one of the first places that that Google
has championed serverless development
this is still my first year here at
Google and
I'm excited to be solving some of these
problems I'm based in Boulder Colorado
but I grew up in California so I'm glad
to be back okay so this makes some
assumptions about you I know a little
bit more than I did when I wrote this
slide which is that about half of you
have used Apps Script before I'm also
curious how many of you have formal
engineering or software training okay
yeah it's a slightly smaller set and
it's slightly disjoint set which is what
we see Apps Script is something that
gets used by people across the spectrum
and we like to see that Apps Script is
part of the strategy for us that lets
people solve their own problems and so
you may or may not have that formal
training but you have problems that can
get solved using some hopefully a small
amount of code and and you use or you
want to use Google for your business and
you want to be able to automate and
extend the products that you get as part
G feet and so what's not quickly about
what Apps Script is broadly well what
it's good for and the actually several
ways that you might use or have already
used Apps Script and and and then this
is a technical session and so will will
then we'll talk about how to use Apps
Script and we'll go through a few
different use cases around a common
theme that show you some of the
different aspects of the product one
thing we won't dive deep into that's a
super important faster the product is
add-ons and the next session in this
room who's given by one of the engineers
on the Apps Script team which is given
by one of the engineers on the team will
cover add-ons in depth and so I don't
want to steal his thunder but please
stick around if you're interested and
then we'll talk a little bit about
features that we don't get to cover in
the hands-on part of the session and
then I'll talk a little bit about where
we go from here
so I actually if there's a server list
JavaScript runtime for DC automation
extension and integration the first key
part here is service and server list I
has you know as many definitions as it
has people who use the word but the key
point is is not that it doesn't run on
servers obviously it runs on servers
it's that you have no role in
provisioning or managing those servers
I think another key piece of this and
it's got talked about yesterday is that
serverless applications are event-driven
you don't have to proactively call this
application from other code because then
you're still managing a server somewhere
that's running some code and so many of
the use cases for Apps Script are those
where the code that you write is
triggered at the right moment by a user
behavior by a change to a document
without your having to write the code
that triggers it javascript this is a
key piece today and at least for the
near term Apps Script is written in
JavaScript and then the last part I want
to highlight is G suite affinity and
that's not to say that you can't use out
script to do other things you can hit
any restful api with a neuro fetch call
you can talk to JDBC and you can talk to
a bunch of Google services via our
built-in api's or directly to their REST
API is by advanced services and Apps
Script but our bread and butter is G
sweet on and that means built-in API is
for talking to dcadt applications for
scripting Gmail Docs sheets and calendar
and but also I event-driven behavior
based on those applications and
extensions and add-ons to those
applications so G suite is really where
where Apps Script starts a few use cases
it's you know
javascript is a turing-complete
programming language you can do just
about whatever you want to but in the
enterprise this is this is really what
we see happening on one way that I might
summarize all of these or some of these
at least is that
applications that used to or often still
do get done in Excel or in Google sheets
where you have a spreadsheet that maybe
has some macros or some scripts attached
to it that is doing more than a
spreadsheet ought to do and frankly
that's often the way that an Apps Script
application itself evolved you open the
script editor in sheets you start typing
some code and before you know it your
spreadsheet is a mission critical
application for your team or the whole
company and you have built your first
Apps Script application we'll talk a
little bit about where you might go from
there to add a UI on top of it and make
it a full-fledged application and also
touch briefly on app maker which is a
tool that was presented yesterday that's
great for building UI on top of app
scripts business logic but key use cases
Enterprise workflows and especially
approval type workflows on anything
document related if you're on G suite
you'll find yourself automating an app
script often resource management we
internally use a tool that's built in
Apps Script to do project management the
daschund drive team at Google and
automation this is anything from writing
a little one-off script to setting up a
time trigger to having a spreadsheet
that generates a report on a bi-weekly
basis and reporting is right there on
the list too and then the three key
integrations to and if you want sheets
or Doc's to talk to a third party
service then Apps Script is a great way
to accomplish that and then lastly
domain admin we have some API is that
let you talk to the admin API I if you
were in the at maker session yesterday
they mentioned a cool new teams tool
that's being deployed as an app maker
template and that's built on top of the
admin SDK which is accessible a script
okay so there are there are four
different ways that folks come to use
Apps Script whether or not you're aware
that you're using apps
rip and by far the the biggest touch
point is as the dock sheets and forms
script editor and so this is the script
editor that you access by going to the
tools script editor menu in dr. sheets
or the vertical ellipsis script editor
menu in forms and that drops you into
the app script editor in the specific
context of that document so that lets
you write some code that operates on
that document you you'll use the script
editor when you have a script that has a
special relationship to a document and
so this is a use case where the sheet is
basically the front end to the
application or where you're adding some
functionality to a to a document to
build your table of contents for example
and the way in which that that special
relationship is captured is with these
three methods and so depending on which
application you're scripting you'll call
these methods to get an object
representing the current document that
you can use to act on that document you
also have access to simple triggers and
which are super easy to code you just
define a non open or non edit function
that code runs every time that event
happens to your document and so on edit
in particular is good for doing complex
work that depends on content across say
a sheet you might use custom functions
for something piecemeal and so you can
also define a custom function that you
can call in your sheet and it will
operate on whichever cells you reference
where you call it in a sheet you want to
do something it's more broad-based that
sweeps in the whole contents of the
sheet you might look to the on edit
trigger the entry point number two is
directly at script google comm you'll
notice if you go to tools script editor
you're editing a script at script google
comm exactly the same product just a
different context and by and large you
can do all of the exact same things and
in one of these
and alone scripts that you can do in a
bound script and the again the decision
tree is is this script does it have a
special relationship with a particular
document if so jewel script editor if
not or even if in the future it might
not have a special relationship to that
one document consider going straight to
script.google.com and using other means
to get access to the documents that you
need to talk to you can use the drive
picker to get a drive file ID and you
can use the document app API to get a
reference to whatever document you want
to talk to a dock for example and so
that's kind of the first decision that
you make when you're approaching app
script is is this script always going to
be attached to this one document and
here are some of the things that you
would do in a standalone app script
project you can just write a quick
utility script and so if you need to
blast a 50 emails or a hundred emails to
people in your org based on rows in a
spreadsheet or some external data source
say write it up in Apps Script hit the
Run button test it out first and and
send those emails off and you can also
build web apps in Apps Script and this
is something that we see leverage
particularly heavily at Google a ton of
the tools that we use internally are
written in Apps Script and when the user
hits your web app which is published at
a well-known URL it runs your Apps
Script code and your Apps Script code
returns HTML back to the back to the
client we have a templating system that
lets you easily code HTML templates and
populate them and we'll actually do a
deep dive on this later in the session
how you build a web app using Apps
Script and you can also build rise to be
web services it's not something that
will go deep into today but our
execution API lets you invoke Apps
Script I a REST API so you can build a
back-end service lastly add ons as
mentioned that is going to get covered
in CP 304 which is the next section in
this room stick around if you like what
you hear or maybe even if you don't cuz
he's cool
okay.i one place I you may have seen a
script before without knowing that it
was Apps Script is AdWords scripts
AdWords scripts run in the Apps Script
runtime and can leverage a bunch of the
Apps Script API s and then lastly at
maker which I've mentioned and which is
being demoed across the street in
Moscone West incredible tool for
building web applications
Apps Script sits behind at makers
deployed application is an Apps Script
web application and as such it has
access to all of the same api's and
facilities that Apps Script does when
you write a server-side script in app
maker that is Apps Script code that
you're writing and if you want to learn
more I think the website is G suite
google.com slash
app maker all one word I definitely
suggest checking it out this is the team
we work really closely with ok so sorry
we're going to do some hands-on coding I
hope it's not too slow stop me if you're
bored to tears and we're going to
organize a speaker of it a little bit
contrived but it shows off a bunch of
the stuff you can do it Apps Script and
by the way we're not going to be
following along our Quick Start site
directly but I we are going to touch on
these three types of scripts that you
see featured in our documentation and
also up there is the web address app
script documentation is the best place
to to start and certainly the place
you'll be coming back to as you as you
go deeper with Apps Script ok so I we're
going to proceed through three versions
of the same application I that
introduced a new types of levels of
functionality the first one is super
simple we're going to build a drive
notifications for ourselves and so we've
got a folder we've asked everybody who's
presenting at the conference to put
their decks in that full
therefore review and approval and we
want to get notified every time
something new comes into that folder
super simple use case but a good
jumping-off point all right
so first thing that we're going to do is
we're going to grab the ID of this
folder in Drive this is our our special
folder and and then we'll create an
asker project sorry I should go back and
you can go directly to script.google.com
or to create an Apps Script project in a
particular place in Drive it's really
handy to just go to the new menu click
more and then Google Apps Script alright
so obviously you memorize the folder ID
and then you recognize it here
so we've stashed that in a in a global
and I we're going to do some processing
on that folder you'll see what we're
going to do on one run of this script as
I step through the code and then I'll
show you how we set it up to run on a
time trigger so you'll get those
notifications regularly and so the first
thing that we're going to do is we're
going to grab a folder object using the
drive app built in API and that
represents that folder that I just
showed you and drive
this lets you script that folder in a
lot of ways and the way that we're going
to do it is to look at what's inside
that folder and you'll see when we go to
install our trigger that runs this
regularly you as the developer are going
to get asked to authorize access to
drive and so everything that Apps Script
does whether it's running is you the
developer or as we'll see by later on if
it's running as the end user
everything is authorized by oo-ahh and
so you are the end user know what data
Apps Script is working with all right so
I get an iterator over the files we're
also going to grab our script properties
script properties is a store key value
pairs for this script you also have user
properties and in the context of a
container-bound scripts script attached
to a document document properties and so
this is your very lightweight
persistence layer for Apps Script so I
when we get to the roadmap I'll talk a
little bit about our vision for storage
and Apps Script but this is where you
start today and it works great for this
okay alright so this is a while loop it
I don't want to single anybody out I did
everybody in here know JavaScript like
the back of your hand okay
so I I this is a while loop this
iterates over a set of code as long as
the condition in the parentheses is true
and so file iterator has this method
that tells us whether it has more files
that we can look at we're just going to
look at each file in this folder until
we run out our strategy here is we want
to know what new files are in this
folder that inherently is a persistence
problem because we have to know what
files we've seen before and that's we're
going to use our properties store for
and so we're forming a key with the file
ID the file flash in the key name that
is that's arbitrary that's up to you as
a developer how you want to define your
key this is with the anticipation you
might put some other stuff in that
property store and so you just
namespacing it and then you're going to
see if you've already put that key in
before if you have that's because the
script ran before and you already saw
that file no action required but if not
then excuse me you're going to set the
property so you know you've seen the
file and then you're going to just push
it on to an array and so that push
method is just adding your file to your
new files array and then lastly if you
found any new files we're going to log
that and I'll show you what that looks
like in the logger feature and we'll
send off an email so I this is
demonstrating the script running as a
standalone la script I'll show you how
to set up on a trigger in a minute but
for now we're just going to select the
process method that we just define and
hit play it's going to run now we'll go
to the logs and we see indeed a new
slides were found in that folder we've
got two decks in that folder we go over
to our Gmail and we also see those two
presentations listed there
okay so the last step to have true
folder notifications is that you don't
have to go and hit the play button every
five minutes and so I in the resources
menu you'll find triggers for the
project configure a trigger here this is
the permission step and so because
you're the person installing the trigger
the script is going to run as you you're
the person with access to the folder
that it operates on so that's by design
and you'll need to authorize access and
so this is the part where you know what
kind of data this script is is accessing
and so it knows who I am but most
importantly are these first two guy
where we see that it's going to going to
be able to look at drive and it's going
to and it's going to manage my email in
the roadmap portion of the talk I will
I'll talk about what we're doing to let
you tailor these scopes more narrowly
and I want to I want to call out that
this first scope is brought this is full
gmail scope where this script all it
does is send an email and so I'll talk
about what we're going to do to make
sure that you don't need to request this
scope when you just want to send email
save that trigger and off you go
so you now have folder notifications at
Drive it's a small use case but it's
also a small amount of code and that's
what we like we want those those easy
things to be easy this was a time
trigger and so in this case we selected
the time driven type and ran it every
five minutes there are a few other kinds
of triggers and some which we'll talk
about some of which we won't but it's a
very similar mechanism to the one that
you would use for example to write a
script that looks up a document whether
one's given to you by user selected
using the drive the drive picker etc and
install a trigger on that document to
get notifications when it changes but in
this case we're just talking about a
simple time driven trigger I should say
I feel free to jump in and ask questions
as you did any time
yeah yep that's a great point and so I
linked in our documentation are the the
quotas for each of our each of our api's
and when you write a script in this way
that runs as the developer that is
something you have to think about
because it will be the developers quota
that will determine how many of those
calls you can make that becomes an
architecture question now it's very
unlikely for example that you as a
developer would write a script that was
processing a folder that was being
accessed by everybody in your
organization on the other hand you might
be writing an application that lets
somebody configure a folder or create a
folder for which they wanted to receive
notifications at that point you'd be
writing a script probably that ran as
that user and it would be that user's
quota who is getting absorbed these
quotas are designed to be permissive
enough that you can get done what you
need to do and typically your
architectural decision about who the
script should run as will dictate that
it run is the user in those cases where
there are going to be a lot of people
impacted by it but if you did find
yourself in a situation say you're
building a web app that used your OAuth
token to access some company-wide data
and present it to the user if that
became a mission critical application
you might have to think about how you
would have that run as the end user
instead and use their quota and when we
get to the roadmap portion I'll also
talk about some of the work that we're
doing on quotas to make them more
flexible ok so I in the second step
we're going to work on a container-bound
scripts that's a script that's attached
to a particular document
we're still working in the same contact
for planning a conference we're still
operating on a folder and drive but
we've also got a sheet that has some
metadata about the the Dex about the
sessions that are reflected in that
folder and so for every session we're
going to have the title of the session
which will also be the title of the
document and a link to the slides a
username of the owner and then
comma-separated list of approvers and
people who have approved and so if this
is used correctly which I have coded no
checks to ensure that it is but wanted
to keep it simple and the approvals
column will be a subset of the approvers
column that is to say if John and Tim
and Lisa need to approve and John and
Lisa have approved and you'll see John
cama cama cama Lisa and approvers and
John comma Lisa and approvers in
approval excuse me
all right so you setup your sheet and
you want to write a script that has a
special relationship with a sheet to do
that you go to the Tools menu and click
click script editor all right
and so here's our script and firstly
we've got the familiar folder ID global
we're still working with that folder and
then we've defined some Global's for for
column indexes and you please speak up
if you've used a strip before and you
have other ways of doing these things
there are many ways to skin these cats
and I would love to hear from other
folks how they how they do these things
and the other thing that we're doing
here and this is one of the cool things
about working with JavaScript Gmail app
is just a Vista global I in the
JavaScript namespace I here we're going
to stub it out we're going to replace it
with our own implementation and that
lets us write a script that works with a
sensitive API that sends email to people
with the confidence that the first time
we run it if there's something wrong if
there's a typo we're going to be the one
to see it instead of the recipient of
the email and so this is going to
leverage larga dot log which is just a
simple logging tool I'll talk a little
bit later about more sophisticated
logging and then there will be a session
at four o'clock today I that goes all
the way down the rabbit hole
on our stackdriver logging integration
and that'll be over in Moscone but here
are simply stubbing out send email so
that our script doesn't actually send
emails until we're ready for it alright
and so first thing we're going to do
we're going to call spreadsheet app
track get active sheet I called this out
earlier this is the way that you get
that document with which you have that
special relationship and abstracted out
find new files it's the same code we saw
previously it's going to leverage
property service to keep track of where
we are and to identify new files and in
the folder
identified above and the new code here
is that we're going to iterate over
those new files and we're going to add a
row to the sheet for every file that we
see and so the the design here is that
you might update the sheet directly but
if not you'll get a row added as people
drop their slides into the folder and
then we're going to iterate over all
roles of the rows of the sheet and we're
going to do I we're going to do some
email based workflow and so I process
row is the relevant call and I'll show
you what it does for each row of the
sheet alright just jumping back briefly
for some minutia and you'll notice that
I rows are 0 index but we have a header
row so we're starting with Row 1 I
should say there are other so we're
calling get data range get display
values that's going to return
two-dimensional array of the values of
the cells in a sheet there are other
methods that allow you to grab a range
those are not 0 index like sheets those
are 1 index but when you're operating on
a JavaScript array 0 index all right and
so here we're doing some some quick
housekeeping we're making sure this is
in good order and so we're going to
check there's an owner for the row and
so when we discover a new set of slides
in this folder I we're adding an entry
in our in our sheet that has a title and
a link to the slides that obviously
doesn't have any in the metadata that's
only stored in sheets and so we need to
let somebody know that those rows need
to be populated so those cells excuse me
and so we will look for an owner
if there's no owner then we'll contact
the owner of the script which of you
once we know the owner then we're going
to look and see if we have approvers for
the flight excuse me could I do that
wrong okay so edit approvers column
index online 73 should be on line 64 an
approvals column index should be online
73 apologies and then we're going to
check our approvals and so this is the
actual business logic this is the
workflow here ah
so I quick use of JavaScript split
function to split up our approvers and
our approvals values and so we have a
raise of people who need to approve this
and people have approve this and then
we're going to iterate over our
approvers and we're going to check
whether they've approved any approver
who hasn't approved is going to get a
notification reminding them today go
check out these slides we need your
sign-off for this session okay so now
we've got some some data in the sheet
and it may have been populated
automatically by our script or it may
have been populated manually and we're
going to add a new session to to our
folder again just showing you how you
would run this manually we'll run the
process function here we get much more
substantial logging these are log
messages generated by our send email
stub by our son stub and so what you can
see here is that this is a lot of
activity that would have happened in the
wild that would have generated real
email messages if we hadn't stubbed out
this method it's a great idea for
testing to put it in the logs first and
make sure that these must just say what
you want them to and we see that our
sheet has been updated we've added a new
row with a link to slides also in those
logs you would have seen messages going
out to you requesting you to populate
the owner for this new row
alright so in my last step here we're
going to build a front-end for our for
our workflow engine and so we're going
to build some UI that is no longer
running as the developer but that runs
as the end user who's going to be
somebody who's involved in the
conference that we're planning and who
has approval responsibility for for one
or more of the presentations will show
them what they need to approve and we'll
let them approve in the UI instead of
going directly to the sheet ok so I
first thing we're going to do we're
going to add a new script file to
isolate the the logic related to our web
app and this is going to be a script
file we'll just call it web app that
defines a do get method I'm sorry it's
covered up by the orange box there but
that's the magic name of a method and a
web app that responds to an HTTP GET
request you can also define a do post
for posts again we're grabbing the
active sheet and here so this do get
method does two things it renders the
list of sessions their person needs to
approve it also processes the requests
that's generated when somebody clicks
the approve button and so here we'll see
some logic that's checking if an
approval is being being granted and
that'll be in the form of a URL
parameter with the document URL and so
we're going to split up the document URL
we're going to extract the ID of the
document that's being approved and so
the requests coming in to this would be
your scripts base URL question mark and
then your doc parameter that's just do
see as we've defined it and which will
have a URL in it which will be the URL
of the slide deck that you're approving
and we know the URL of a slide deck has
a ID for the document in it before the
trailing slash so we'll split it up and
we'll take the second-to-last portion of
that URL and we know that that's our
document ID so this is just how we grab
the document ID
being approved then we're going to call
session get active user and this is
interesting this is the part where we
identify the person at the keyboard this
is not you the developer but this is the
person accessing your web app because
that person has a Google login and it's
signed in their identity is already
known they will see an OAuth prompt
because we're going to be looking at
some data on their behalf but the login
flow is already it's part of their
Google login and so we're going to grab
that identity and we're going to get
their username as part of their email
address alright so now we're generating
our response and the loop that we're
about to walk through does two things
and if this is the document that's being
approved we're going to update the
approvers we're also we're going to add
every document to an array of approvable
documents and we're going to use that to
then render an HTML response that shows
the list of documents that this user
needs to approve alright so and this is
an example of using the get range method
on a sheet those methods are one index
not zero index so just an important
detail to remember and we're going to
grab the approvers value for the current
row of the sheet that's who needs to
approve this session and we've
abstracted out parsing the approvers
it's a little bit of a mouthful we're
going to split on commas and for the
empty string we just have to handle the
case where we wind up with an array with
one empty string in it in that case
there are no approvers and so just
splitting up on commas
here we're asking is the current user
and approver of this document so
remember we're iterating over all rows
of the sheet we're only going to do
anything for those rows where this user
needs to approve our slides and we're
going to grab the approvals and then
we're going to why are we checking again
here all right okay so we are iterating
over our approvals and we're seeing if
this approver has approved this document
yet if not then we're going to include
it in the approval of list excuse me
we're going to add it to the approvals
list regardless and but we're also going
to stash a value that tells us whether
it's been approved all right
lastly we're going to build an object
and so here just for every row in the
sheet that represents a document that
need somebody's approval we're going to
have an entry in an array that tells us
the title URL whether it's been approved
and then the URL that you would have to
hit to approve it and that's the URL
with the doc parameter that we know how
to process so that we can approve an
entry in the sheet okay cool I will look
next at at how we do templating and so
here we are grabbing our HTML template
and we're shoving the data in approvable
into that template and rendering it this
is just a classic separation of
controller and view of business logic
from the view and so here we know what
our approvals are and we know we're
going to write a template that knows how
to render those out to the client and so
we write this out it's boilerplate we
call template dot evaluate and that's
going to return our template HTML with
values populated so now I'll show you
what that template looks like all right
you'll create a new HTML file
call it page this part gets written out
for you and basic HTML the interesting
part here is the code that we write and
so we're going to render a table that
has a list of the documents that need to
be approved it's going to have an action
button that lets you as the approver
approve a document so I hear what you're
saying is JavaScript code embedded in
HTML angle bracket question mark is the
is the escape sequence to do that and so
I approvable here if you'll recall we
passed in to our templates and so I
properties of the template are
accessible from within your HTML
template code as JavaScript variables
using that escape sequence and so I
template approvable sets that approvable
array i on the template and it's this
for loop here that iterates over those
approvals and now once we close the
escape sequence we're back in HTML and
so we're just writing out a PR for every
document in our list and then we're
going to render the control button to
approve the document or we'll render out
a checkbox if it's already been approved
and so you'll see here in the second the
second block of the if statement I if
this document hasn't been approved then
we're going to render an empty check box
and that's going to link to that
approval URL that identifies this
document as the one that you again you
the end-user or the application want to
approve and then we're going to render
out the title with a link to the
document so that you can review it close
our curly braces okay so in the publish
menu you'll find deploy as web app this
is how you tell Apps Script that you
want this code to run in response to
HTTP requests and to give you a
well-defined URL that users can go to to
use your application this is all it
takes you write some HTML you write some
business logic and then you deploy it as
a web app and
tell you where users go to access that
application and so couple of key things
here I execute the app as the user
accessing the web app this is designed
to be a user centric queue and this gets
to your question as well this is a case
where your quota is not going to be
absorbed as a developer if this were not
conference planning but vacation
planning and everybody in the company
we're using it then you would only be
absorbing end users quote ads they hit
it and then who has access to the app
we're going to allow everybody in the
domain to access the application and
then we get our URL and so this is the
application URL and you may choose to
map this with a URL shortener or even a
sub-domain
that's one way that we see folks I kind
of I putting the stamp of approval on an
application that's built using Apps
Script and so the folks know that it's
sanctioned by IIT by the folks who
control the DNS record alright so now
we're experiencing this web application
as a user the first step is going to be
to review the permissions that it
requires again I'll talk about how we're
working on this this is a long list of
permissions and the the big ones though
that you see our Gmail Drive and um
manage spreadsheets and so here's what I
see these are the presentations that
need my approval where I'm in that list
of approvers and neither of these is
approved and so I have a checkbox next
to each of them after reviewing this
presentation I click the check box page
loads we render again and this time we
render a check mark instead of an open
box because I've approved this document
and here we see I've been added to the
approvals column of the document so the
spreadsheet is is up-to-date what we've
really done here is we've replaced the
spreadsheet as an interface to our
application with a web application
that's tailored to the use case and it
also prevents the user from doing stuff
they ought not to do with this sheet
great so that was a walkthrough of its
kind of three key deployment types and
in the context of one use case and I
just wanted to quickly touch on stuff
that didn't get swept into it because
there really is there's a lot this
product has been around since 2009 and
it's grown significantly so I built in
api's we saw a few of these we saw Drive
app we saw spreadsheet app and there are
about a dozen of these built-in api's
they are designed to be ergonomic and
accessible to people who don't write a
ton of code in most cases those api's
mirror and are basically wrappers around
a public rest HTTP API that you can use
to talk to these services and we package
them up in an ergonomic easy way if
you're familiar with j2ee beans then the
the method naming pattern will be super
familiar and it's a great way to quickly
automate gee sweet and we also give you
access to other Google and GCP api's as
advanced services those our API is where
you do effectively hit them at the in
the existing restful form we just put
some some niceties around them in Apps
Script to make it easier to make those
calls we define school Google script run
this is in the context of add-on
specifically again if you're around for
the next session you'll see how this can
get used to generate a call from the
client-side that runs code on the server
side this is all you also what you would
use in app maker if you wanted to run a
server-side script in response to a
client event super easy to call any
function that you've defined an app
script from the client and the four
o'clock session over in Moscone will
dive deep our stack driver logging
integration is currently an EAP folks
who are in the ad maker EAP will have
access to this feature and and it lets
you log messages using the familiar
console dot log I method and those
messages
Oh to stackdriver logging and they're
they're available for analysis and for
monitoring and it's a super powerful
tool for monitoring your application and
I would recommend it highly for anybody
who's doing something sophisticated or
that has lots of users log out log
becomes cumbersome when you're trying to
work with more than one end user Adams
Ruach sheets and forms that's the next
session custom menu items sidebars and
dialogues for Docs sheets and forms and
so you can define these in an add-on if
you want everybody to be able to install
them or if you just want to build some
UI around a particular document and you
can you still have access to the same
method you can add menu items you can
add a sidebar that has your custom UI
you can trick your sheet out to your
heart's content and with these custom UI
elements in sheets and you can find
custom functions for sheets we see those
used a lot in vertical specific use
cases especially around finance but
others as well to extend sheets just
with custom functions that do stuff that
the built-ins don't both event in
time-based triggering we talked a little
bit about both of those and then you can
use our execution API with an OAuth
token that you obtain or generate for
the user that runs in the context of
that OAuth token the Apps Script code
that you've defined and so this is a way
that you would build a restful web
service with with Apps Script that does
something more than existing G suite
api's do for you that interleaves
functionality of GAAP is or it possibly
brings data in from an on-prem or a
third party source here's a full list of
on the left-hand side built-in services
and some additional script services for
programming primitives and JDBC and
advanced services these are restful api
s that are scriptable in Apps Script
without using urlfetch to do explicit
HTTP requests
all right the fun part
the lawyers literally made me put this
up here
this is this is the usual and this is
where we think we're going on the
timeline that we think we're doing it no
formal commitment but the stuff that
we're doing is important so I hope we do
it on the dates that you see here so the
first thing that we're working on I is a
a step toward improving developer and
end-user visibility into the behavior of
app script and often your scripts run in
the background in response to triggers
they don't have a UI and whether to bug
them or just to make sure that
everything's going well you want to see
basically your top you want to see your
process list and so this is something
that's currently NTT I you can go and
see all of the scripts that are running
as you various filters available with
their with their result this is it's
great for debugging but it's also great
for as an end user understanding what's
going on with the application that you
use in your day-to-day we're working on
a new management and deployment API this
is geared toward more sophisticated
users of Apps Script and more
sophisticated workflows this is the way
that you would use your own developer
tools and in particular your own source
code management with Apps Script this
API will let you push scripts in to Apps
Script and deploy your app script
project programmatically and you can use
this also also to do continuous
integration and automated testing with
Apps Script I write your code commit to
version control I push it up to your dev
server deploy your dev server make sure
it works
push that code up to your production
server and deploy your production server
with with the new code and explicit
OAuth scopes so this is something I
mentioned a couple of times and today
Apps Script infers the OAuth scopes that
are required to do the things that the
script does and so if you use drive app
you're going to request drive scope to
use Gmail app today we request full
Gmail scope this is a way that you can
be more narrowly narrowly tailored and
it's just a first step toward being
better about requesting kind of a
minimum of
is that an application needs which is
something that everybody cares about
this first step you'll be able to list
out the Scopes that you want as an
override to our automatically
determining them so you'll be able to
narrowly tailor those scopes to exactly
what your your script is doing and just
announced this morning Gmail add-ons
this is in PT like Docs sheets and forms
add-ons gmail add-ons will be written in
Apps Script
unlike Docs sheets and forms email
add-ons use a domain-specific markup to
render cards and the cool thing about
that is that Gmail has written the code
that renders the card and that code runs
on the web and in mobile and so you as a
developer of a gmail add-on don't have
to think about what's your UI going to
look like in all these different
contexts you just render a card using
their markup and it displays images or
links or lists lets you add a bunch of
richness around a message that matches
your your criteria for running me out on
we're really excited about this slides
up and slide that on and so we're going
to have a built in API for scripting
slides it's long overdue really excited
to have it landing and and also the
ability to build out onto the slides in
the same way that you do for daxing
conforms there's a short link here if
you want to sign up for the TT if you
use slides heavily please give it a look
back and parallel jogs this is partly in
response to quota concerns and one of
the one of the things that developers
run into when they try to do big jobs in
Apps Script is the 30 minute or six
minute execution time limit depending on
what context you're running in we are
building out a service that lets us
still maintain some of those important
assumptions about the longest that a
script could possibly run but while
letting you kick off a big job and not
have to worry about how it gets split up
between Apps Script processes and so
you'll pass in an array of tasks that
are just units of work you'll tell us
what function you want to run on each of
those units of work and then you'll tell
us what function you want to run with
the results of each of those units of
work
and we'll split that up among app script
tasks will paralyze them to the extent
that we can this is intended to serve
the use case of large batch jobs that
would normally take a long time or
consume a lot of quota and then lastly
and a little bit further out we're
thinking about I develop er and admin
visibility and that's kind of a high
level view of script else without having
to dive into logs or just look at the
most recent execution and to the point
you into the execution history you see
in the process dashboard but to let you
easily navigate from lots of different
scripts you work with the adoption of
your scripts I get notified of
deprecations etc and we are in earlier
phases of that project but we think it's
super important to let developers and
then downline admins have a lot of
visibility into what's happening in
their domain whether the scripts are
working whether they're calling
duplicated api's and so forth all right
I just a few quick links and two
resources depending what level you're
you're working at a great intro I hear
first in the list thanks to our own
Wesley is I at 1 sx eud I'll leave that
up for a second so folks can snap photo
or write it down if you want to check
any of these out
[Music]
[Music]